coach Neil is joining the party and she
sat down with the cast from the new Star
Wars film and clearly there's a reason
why you brought heavenly lightsaber this
is the very lightsaber the Luke
Skywalker himself Mark Hamill and Daisy
Ridley just gave me a Jedi left and
within Kevin let's just say the force is
now strong and entertainment tonight
this is a strong stance like heavy and
your feet weighty like that and what's
like that's not what's the vibe the
thought is you just hurt my friend
you're gonna you didn't pay so you can't
really tell from that behind-the-scenes
moment but Daisy mastered her super
skills at Lightspeed according to her
trainer tougher to deal with was the
loss of Carrie Fisher who makes her last
appearance in the franchise what was
your favorite memory of working with her
on the film the first time around there
was a behind-the-scenes release where me
and her were dancing between takes and
this time captured us singing between
takes it was probably that it was the
sort of sense of just joy that she
bought to sex we had a lot of our scenes
together and hold out my hand and we
would dance a little bit the last Jedi
continues the Skywalker saga with ray
and Luke joining forces John boyega is
back as finn and laura dern joins the
cast I've seen this roster
it scared me enough that
so what scares this Jedi Master in real
life
the paparazzi he's gone to great lengths
to avoid them even faking an illness
my daughter Chelsea said dad get in the
wheelchair and take the dog on your lap
it's sort of backfired and all these
papers started writing stories about you
know that I was in ill health and you
know on death's door but nobody cares
about this oh poor you